(guitar strumming)
- [Ryan, James,
Ahmed] Dead Kevin.
(television changing channels)
- You guys eat my pizza?
- Uh, what was the question?
- Jack, I had a
personal pizza in here,
that's been waiting
for me all day.
God-dammit dude.
- 'Cus, we, I thought
maybe earlier, I'd be like,
let's have some pizza,
but then, like I said,
we haven't eaten in a week.
- Jack you're babbling.
Ahmed?
No?
- We didn't eat it, but
I'll buy you a new one.
- That seems like you ate it.
I bought ranch.
- This week's been
a blur, you know.
Lot of stuff, lot of stuff
going on in both of our lives,
you know.
- Jack shut your mouth.
Jesus, fuck.
My Goddamn pizza,
fucking, goddammit.
Didn't eat it?
'Cause I don't...
(exhales sharply)
I work all day.
And this fuckin' spreadsheet.
I'm not a fucking
spreadsheet guru.
Goddamn, fucking pizza.
(exhales sharply)
(crunches loudly)
(package crumples)
- I'll go get pizza.
(guitar strums)
- Hi I'm Ryan, the heart
throb from Dead Kevin Sketch.
Do your room mates
ever eat your food?
Well fuck them!
And tell us about it
in the comment section
and subscribe to our
channel Dead Kevin Sketch.
A freeze pop.
(high-pitched whining)